but let's just digest that Florida I'd
love to race I mean that is eye-popping
Dana yeah so again I think Governor
DeSantis who uh had a tough election his
first time around has shown himself to
be a very competent governor who one who
really listens to the people of Florida
responds to them you know he was a very
a very different Governor when it came
to covid you had people fleeing from New
England states in order to move there
because the schools were opened and it
they just run he runs the state very
well and he wasn't afraid also to reach
out to different people and that number
in Miami-Dade if that holds true it'll
be great to get some Karl Rove analysis
on that as well as Florida if you
remember well of course he remembers the
election in 2000 a big deal the
interesting thing about his opponent
Charlie Crist I don't know if you would
have realized this he will be the first
person in Florida to lose a Statewide
race as a Republican an independent and
a
democratulations campaign headquarters
right now exploding in Tampa tonight I
think they're watching Fox we welcome uh
Harold Ford Jr former Tennessee
Congressman co-host of the five welcome
to the panel uh with this big Republican
win we'd love you to weigh in
but I do want to read this this is from
David ploff the President Obama's OA
campaign manager who said quote the
Obama Coalition in Florida is gone wow
that's pretty stunning if you look at
the numbers here Miami-Dade County
Hillsborough County Osceola County these
are places they did not win uh
Republicans now they are winning in big
numbers well Democrats have proved I
think not to be able to adapt to
changing political circumstances in a
situation clearly we've gone through
covet all the things that spawned from
it from supply chain challenges to the
challenge of getting our kids back to
school a governor DeSantis is being
rewarded for that uh and I think if
you're going to counter him you have to
counter him with some substance you've
got to counter him with an alternative
course that's going to make life better
for citizens in Florida and frankly it
doesn't look as if it doesn't look as if
the the three time did you say loss is a
Democrat a republican independent
Congressman Chris Governor Chris was not
able to mount that message if you're if
you Governor DeSantis this win tonight I
think in many ways not only roles
Democrats but it also helps it will rule
Republicans as well because some choices
are going to have to be made very soon
about whom is the national leader who's
the leader of the party or for
Republicans is it Ron DeSantis is it
Donald Trump or is it someone else but
tonight is a night for governor Sanders
congratulations to him hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else